so today we're pleased to have tatsu
hashimoto here with us um tatsu did his
phd at mit did a post talk at stanford
spent one year
as a researcher at microsoft semantic
machines and he's joining stanford um as
of last month as a fresh assistant
professor so welcome to
welcome back to stanford he'll actually
be teaching 221 in the winter
so if you like his talk you should go
tell all your friends to have them take
221 in the in the winter
so tatsu has worked on a number of areas
from computational biology text
generation and nlp but he's probably
really well known for his work on
you know robustness and machine learning
and i think throughout this course um
we've emphasized that machine learning
is something that's really
being deployed in the real world all
over right now and having real impact in
the world just last week we heard from
you know about this so i think
robustness of machine learning systems
is a really really important area and
tatsu is an expert in this so i'm really
happy to have him tell us
what robustness and machine learning is
all about and where things are at the
moment so take it away tatsu
okay great
um so i want to start with emphasizing
sort of what percy already said which is
that there's been this enormous and
rapid progress in machine learning
over the last decade or so and
especially in tasks like image
recognition um 10 years ago
or errors were at the level of like 20
30 percent and human level performance
was you know sub uh seven percent
and there was this huge gap in
performance and everyone said it'll take
a long time to reach human level
performance
but nowadays really human level
performance is being achieved on all
sorts of tasks image recognition as of
say 2015 but also in tasks like natural
language processing and much more
challenging reasoning-based tasks
these systems are now getting really
close if not exceeding human performance
and so machine learning has really
achieved these sort of great successes
and they're being deployed and we can
sort of ask what is machine learning
been good at and what is it good at and
it's really good at extracting patterns
from training data
and applying this on a test distribution
to do some prediction
and so we can think of this as you know
classic digit prediction task you have
some images of digits and you need to
return the you know numbers that are
associated with them as long as sort of
the source and the target distributions
look the same
modern machine learning systems based on
large amounts of data and neural nets
are going to do exceedingly well on
these tasks but really the challenge is
what if
um the training data doesn't look very
much like the test data
um in these cases we're gonna have a lot
of challenges so on the
image that i put here you know in the
source domain we have these like black
and white images and sort of desaturated
settings and now at test time you have
these yellow cabs in new york um and you
know your predictions might not work so
well once you have this what's called
distribution shift
and so once we start to think about
going beyond just sort of data that
looks like the training data we see a
lot of problems on the horizon and we've
discovered a lot of these problems
beyond tesla accuracy
and i'm going to at the beginning of
this talk cover sort of three classes of
problems
that hopefully
you'll think about as you sort of
continue on your journey in ai and
machine learning the first one is sort
of discrimination
and performance on minorities
another one is vulnerability to
adversaries in high stakes secure
applications um and then last one which
is a little bit more abstract but i will
get into this in more detail is that
models don't really display an
understanding of the tasks that they're
actually performing and this is going to
be a little bit abstract but because the
ai focused class i think this is an
important thing uh to be discussing and
going through
and so sort of the unifying theme like
these seem like very different problems
right like problems that machine
learning systems have today
but really they're all sort of connected
with a single underlying theme and that
many of these problems can be cast as
these problems in robustness
and so when the training distribution
and the test distribution are different
these models break down because they're
broke
so to start with let's talk about sort
of discrimination and fairness and
minority groups
so
a really typical thing that happens in a
lot of machine learning systems today is
that there's sort of a majority group
let's say you know western cultures
english text
or
sort of males in many cases so in this
majority group that dominates the
training data you get extremely good
superhuman performance in these systems
and often you're going to be deploying
this to a wide variety of users and so
you will have minorities using your
system
and in these cases you end up with
horrible sort of near random performance
and you can sort of immediately see how
this is a discrimination issue and sort
of an equity issue
and i'm going to go over a lot of these
examples in turn but these just show up
in all sorts of places that you might
not initially think about when you think
about fairness problems like say a
dependency parsing or video captioning
face recognition is a very common one
that people probably already know
but in these sorts of like common widely
deployed ml systems you start to see
these gaps between how these systems
perform
on majority groups versus minority
groups
so the first one that i think is
probably maybe surprising to many people
that there's these kinds of gaps
it's a test called dependency parsing so
the input is just sort of sentences
tokenized and sort of split up so an
example here is bills on ports and
immigration we're submitted by senator
brownback republican of kansas um and
the output is that you're supposed to
analyze sort of the syntactic structure
of this sentence and create dependencies
between what are called headwords uh and
they're dependent and so you end up with
what looks like a tree here
um and so the sentence above like the
bills on ports and so on um can be
parsed into this v-shaped uh structure
here on the bottom and so this is called
dependency parsing because there's these
explicit dependencies uh between tokens
that show up um in your data
and in sort of classical nlp pipelines
such as say if you want to extract
relations between uh people or entities
you know who was the person that
submitted the bill in the sentence for
example you might use something like a
dependency parser to look at
dependencies in your sentence and to
extract relations right so this is sort
of a first step in terms of uh getting
these kinds of more sophisticated
analyses in these sort of classical
pipelines nowadays many things are sort
of end-to-end and neural um but that
sort of decide the point here
and what's sort of surprising or maybe
not surprising if you've thought about
these kinds of problems is that these
parsers do much much worse on
data that's not commonly used to train
these dependency parsers so this is a
study from
sue lemblaja in 2016 where they took a
bunch of different dependency parsers
and applied them to text
from standard american english as well
as african-american vernacular and
that's the column labeled
aalis
and the performance here is measured by
what's called label attachment score so
that's how well do you reconstruct the
tree
and the numbers here you know you might
not really know how to internalize this
but you see these big gaps right so in
terms of
standard american english you get these
57 uh sort of f1 score type accuracy and
then 43 in african-americans and you get
a 14-point gap and sort of
state-of-the-art for this task say you
know you're competing over like one
point difference so these are enormous
gaps uh once you go from standard
american english to african-american
vernacular
and these kinds of things can have huge
downstream impact um if they're used in
things like relation extraction or qa
systems right because texts from
african-americans are just
systematically not going to get
extracted into say relations or entities
when you build knowledge bases and
things like that
and so you might sort of see how this
begins to affect these kinds of minority
groups
through these kinds of robustness
problems
another example
is video captioning so many of you have
already interacted with systems like
this through youtube's video captioning
system
where the input is you know you have a
video with some spoken text audio and
the output is text captions that are
automatically added to the video
and these things are increasingly
important because say if you have um
i know that in medical domains if you
have medicaid funded sort of videos that
you need to put up on the internet you
need to have captions and so in these
cases you have you either run these
systems or you have people transcribe
the videos
and what's been found is that these
kinds of systems work a lot worse for
women um so this is a study by rachel
chapman 2017
where she basically showed that if you
took uh male versus female speakers and
you ran them through
youtube's video captioning system you
guys systematically higher error rates
for women and you see that sort of the
median error rate is essentially the
upper quartile error rate for maps so
that's actually a pretty substantial
difference in the word error rate
between these two groups
and you also see sort of expected
differences between dialects which is
you know scottish speakers get
substantially worse
um video captioning accuracy uh whereas
you know speakers from california uh get
really good word error rates and so you
know you can sort of see how this sort
of manifests right youtube being based
in california obviously dog fooded with
people with californian accents
and when tested out of distribution on
scottish speakers suddenly performs a
lot worse
and so this is the kind of robustness
problems that you initially don't think
about because you sort of think about
well is our model performing well on you
know really a complex uh input and so
you might put in some really complex
inputs as a california speaker but
really you haven't tested out of
distribution on scottish accents
and then we'll come to another example
which many of you hopefully already know
in facial recognition this has sort of
been really widely discussed even in the
media and just to go over what the task
is the input
is images um
possibly containing a face or not
depending on the task
and you can do many sort of things with
these images and there are many outputs
that are associated with face
recognition or identification tasks
and so you might ask is there a face in
this image and that's sort of face uh
sorry recognition um you might need to
match a given face to uh database of
faces and that would be identification
um or you might need to predict
attributes is this um
face
a female face or a male face or you know
happy or sad you have many sort of
attribute prediction tasks that can be
built on top of faces
and
this is one of the original studies i
think in terms of highlighting
how bad these kinds of systems can be
in sort of widespread ways and so
there's a study from mit media lab
gender shades and joy bullani vilam
winnie in 2018
where she basically took
a whole bunch of um portraits of
legislators from different countries
african and i think northern european
and ran them through
different face
attribute prediction systems for whether
or not they were male or female and what
you can sort of see on this uh on the
top right
is that dark female skin uh results in
much worse
gender predictions compared to
light skinned males where you basically
have perfect prediction
and these kinds of things are
pretty problematic if you've been
testing your systems on light-skinned
people you think your system is near
perfect and so you might be using it for
really high-stakes tasks
where you need a 100 performance but
then when applied to these sort of
darker skinned uh demographic groups you
end up with substantially worse
performance and so you're not you don't
you don't even realize um the kinds of
harms that you're causing by using these
kinds of systems
and what's sort of problematic and sort
of you can see is that they reflect a
lot of the benchmark data that's been
constructed for this task and so on the
right on the right bottom here
um you see
the distribution of sort of skin color
and gender for benchmark data sets in
this kind of like sort of gender
um identification from face image tasks
and what you see is that they're sort of
a systematic underrepresentation of both
females and darker skinned demographics
and you might say you know this really
just reflects the underlying data
distribution and so maybe all we need to
get is you know unbiased data you hear
this term a lot from i think people who
um haven't thought too deeply about
problems of robustness but the issue is
that there's really no such thing as
truly unbiased data in the sense that
there will always be an underrepresented
group if you slice your data fine enough
so we need to really just go beyond
thinking about balancing the data set
and we need to think about how can we
make our models work well
even for really small groups really
small demographic groups and even
individuals
another task
that has these kinds of issues is
language identification so as an input
you might be uh working at twitter and
you need to identify the language of a
tweet so that you can run a machine
translation system and automatically
translate a tweet into someone's uh sort
of speaking language
but in order to do this you need to
first identify what text the tweet is
written in right and so you might have a
lot of different kinds of inputs and
this figure one shows the challenge in
this task
so you might have um dialectical text so
the top one is on nigerian english
the second one is sort of sort of irish
tweets and the last one you can have
code switching so you can have a mix of
both indonesian and english and so in
language identification when you're
given these kinds of tweets you need to
identify the source language
that they were written in
and so the output of the task is the
language
what's sort of been identified is that
there's systematic biases once again in
language identification and sort of one
that's immediately a little bit
troubling is that african-american
english often gets identified not as
english so there's sort of like an
implicit normative judgment being made
here that african-american vernacular is
uh not english and you see this uh error
right here
as aae having almost double the array of
language identification compared to a
more standard american english
data set
you also see this across languages and
this is a study by jergens at all in
2017
where if you sort sort of the languages
by the human development
index of the countries um you see that
there's this decreasing uh recall or
decreasing accuracy um as the countries
get less and less developed and that's
because often these kinds of countries
have under-resourced
data sets and so there isn't as much
data with which to train these language
identification systems
so you see the systematic biases in
terms of how well developed and how
internet connected these countries are
and this this leads to sort of
representational harms right like if
you're an african-american english
speaker and a system you know tells you
that you're not speaking english that's
kind of harmful and there's also utility
harms right like if your text doesn't
automatically get translated to english
you know you're going to
your tweets won't reach as wide of an
audience
and so you can think of these
as having sort of pretty serious
implications for fairness as machine
learning becomes more widespread and
more useful
and more impactful
and so there's these problems of
serious sort of active discrimination um
where this was a story in the new york
times where
um a face
recognition system identified a person
as being a criminal and this was faulty
and this was essentially the only reason
for arresting this michigan man and so
if you have a system that's
much more error prone on african
americans you're basically going to have
a much higher error rate when deploying
these kinds of algorithms so you have
these active discriminations and harms
that are being done but on the other
side right we think that you know as
people taking machine learning and
studying machine learning we think that
these kinds of technologies are broadly
beneficial and useful um and increase
efficiency and so you know there's a
study um by eric barone yolfsen which
says you know the application of machine
translation systems um increased you
know exports on ebay by 17.5 because
it's really easy to translate text and
so people from other countries can buy
your product but if for example
language identifiers can't identify your
language and so you can't use machine
translation systems then you don't get
these benefits right so you get unequal
access to sort of the fruits of these
kinds of ai systems and so this can lead
to sort of uh harms in both ways you
don't get access to the benefits um and
you get these kinds of active harms from
the errors that these systems make
um and i'm gonna stop here because i
think fairness is a topic that many
people have
uh feelings and comments about and i'd
be happy to sort of just sit around and
discuss for the next couple of minutes
if anyone has questions um about sort of
how fairness and these sort of
robustness questions interact with each
other
yeah uh there's a bunch of questions in
the chat oh
yes uh sorry i have full screen so i'm
gonna
give me a moment to pull up the chat um
yes okay
okay i see it now
ah okay so
i think
there are um i'll start with the first
question which is um
having um balanced unbiased data is not
enough and so this is a very subtle
point so there are data that you can
construct that will make you
um robust to certain kinds of groups
right like so let's let's go back to um
just this slide
um so if we look at this sort of
distribution of data it's clear that at
least for this like top one aliens uh
we're probably going to have some sort
of bias in terms of light versus dark
skin because dark skin is so
underrepresented
um but if we balance this data out right
we might still have um sort of
unbalanced unbalanced uh demographics in
certain other areas right maybe it's not
uh dark versus light skin but maybe it's
geographic region it might be income
right these kinds of problems are
enumerable and so what you really need
and not is not necessarily the search
for this unreachable perfectly balanced
data set
but sort of a model that can sort of do
well on small data sets or small um
amounts of data so you want to have a
model that can take in these kinds of
imbalanced data and do well both on the
male and or sorry the dark and the light
skin and the important thing in this
task is there's no real trade-off right
like there's no real reason that you
can't do well on both the light and dark
skin and i think that's the sort of
crucial structure here like if you can
do well on both groups
then it's not really about the amount of
data or the distribution of data it's
more about the model and sort of how
you're learning it
and the second question is there way to
audit models without having access
to the model um
so that's a interesting question i mean
i'm not sure if you meant by this like
access to the model's outputs or
something else like if you have access
to the model's outputs right you can
perform a study like gender shades where
you run the model
on certain
sort of challenge examples and you look
at what the error rate is and you say
well clearly we are doing much worse on
dark skinned females than light-skinned
males so there's some sort of sort of
bias so you can audit models that way it
becomes much harder to audit models if
you can't execute the model on your own
data then you'll have to do something a
little bit tricky and it requires
very specialized conditions i think to
be able to audit those kinds of models
also feel free to ask follow-up
questions if i didn't answer any of
these
so uh similar to the issue with a person
in michigan there has been efforts in
applying ai to model future problem
human behavior
um
oh this is a comment yes um and that's
highly problematic uh i think in one of
the earlier uh slider talks there was a
discussion about sort of how
amplification and feedback effects are
really insidious and yeah so predicting
the future and actioning on predicted
future behavior is even more problematic
than the task i described here because
acting on the real world will change the
outcome right so if you predict that
crime will happen in a certain area you
assign more police and you find more
crime that's going to lead to a pretty
vicious feedback loop so you need to
really think about
sort of the whole socio technical system
rather than just the classification
system narrowly narrowly when you're in
those settings
um
the last one uh it seems that we can
always slice our data into more cell
populations to test for fairness are
there industry standards for what we
should usually start with
that's a great question and also a
really important academic one um so
there is a sort of
easy answer which is that a lot of
research and a lot of industry work has
focused on sort of legally protected
groups
and that's a well-defined set of
attributes that you can't discriminate
on and so you can group by those you can
group by intersections of those and you
can say those are the groups i shouldn't
discriminate on
but sort of academically this seems
unsatisfying because why should those be
the only things we care about and
there's a lot of work on sort of
individualized fairness making sure that
you do well on sort of individual people
make sure you treat people that are
similar similarly and things like that
and that's a whole active area of
research and sort of not really
something where there's an obvious and
clear answer yet
okay
any other final questions before i move
on
okay um so now i'm going to move on to
sort of the second point that i talked
about before that machine learning
systems aren't really secure and can't
really be used in many high-stakes
situations
so
i'm going to start with one of the most
well-known examples of this um called
adversarial examples
where on the left we have an image this
is a panda and a classification system
gets this mostly right so it's panda
with 57 confidence that's great now what
we're going to do is we're going to add
a very specially designed and visually
imperceptible perturbation so this
middle panel looks like complete noise
we scale it down so that it looks just
like zeros and then we add it to the
panda image and we get the image on the
right now we run our image classifier
and what we get out is it's almost
certainly a given which is you know
completely wrong
and so what this tells us is
we can find visually imperceptible
perturbations that lead to
very confident misclassifications and
i'm not going to you know show you the
results of this adversarial example
stuff but you can do this to almost any
system and you can completely and
catastrophically destroy the accuracy of
all of these systems and this also
happens in nlp systems and so on and so
this is a really sort of hard to avoid
and almost sort of universal behavior uh
and i want to show you how you know
sort of robust this kind of behavior is
um and so it doesn't have to be images
on a computer screen it can happen by
putting little black and white patches
to a stop sign and so on the left a
system is going to classify that as a
yield instead of a stop sign
the middle one is a fun 3d printed
toy where if you try to run an object
recognizer it will say gun from almost
any angle
and the right one is adversarial sticker
where if you stick it anywhere and you
take an image it's going to say that
it's a toaster
instead of a banana which is what it
should be so these are very many
different formats but you have this uh
same and kind of disturbing phenomena
where
you know it's obvious to us that
something shouldn't be
tricking us like you know black and
white patches that are that small or
like weird texture on a turtle shouldn't
really be fooling us into changing our
predictions but it really fools
these image classifiers
and when you first see this you think
there must be a really simple patch
right like maybe you like run it through
a jpeg compressor maybe you add a little
bit of extra noise to every image
and so this has led to an enormous
number of papers
over like a hundred or so over the last
um five or six years in which people
have tried a lot of different things to
defend
against
these kinds of what's called adversarial
perturbations but the problem is that
every time someone comes up with a
defense um soon after
someone's gonna someone breaks it by
finding you know a better attack or even
somewhat more disturbingly just running
the old attack for longer
and so it kind of seems like this is a
really persistent
um and serious phenomena and
i think the recent view of a lot of
these adversarial example um
type
problems is not that you know there's
some
really degenerate artifact about the way
we train models or the way we um
optimize things it's really just the
fact that there are a lot of ways to
have a high performance prediction
system and many of the ways in which we
can predict accurately rely on these
what we're going to call non-robust
features
and so when we try to say classify a dog
or a cat or so on we as humans rely on
these what
we're going to term robust features
right we try to identify eyes and snout
in these parts
and so these kinds of things are pretty
robust to pixel level perturbations but
actually you know low level textures and
really small image patches are also very
predictive of classes of dogs versus
cats let's say
and who are we to say right that that's
like an incorrect way to make the
predictions because when we train the
model
all we're saying is you know just
classify these dogs and cats well
and so you can think of this as saying
you know our problem is underspecified
and there are many ways to get a good
classifier and some of them really rely
on the use of these sort of like
non-robust features
um
and
this has kind of serious security
implications right
um if you're trying to make a
self-driving car system
um
you know the stop sign being classified
as a yield is pretty bad you might run
over a pedestrian and this really
prevents the application of machine
learning systems in things like
um
self-driving cars or at least we should
be very hesitant if we believe that
these kinds of problems are inherent
right because the world is kind of
designed so that they're um really
easily perceptible to humans and not
necessarily designed so that small
perturbations say by putting on stickers
don't change um stop signs to yield
signs um and in other cases right vision
systems i think are being increasingly
being used in high-stakes applications
like we might reasonably imagine say
right at a tsa checkpoint there's a
camera that's running and it tries to
identify whether or not you have a gun
right and if you can make these
adversarial examples that say make a gun
a knot gun or a turtle a gun that seems
very problematic right we can't use
vision systems for those kinds of high
stakes applications that we might want
to use them for
and so both of these really pose
challenges for the use of machine
learning in these like sort of high
stakes life or death kind of uh settings
um
and i'm gonna stop here um to take
questions about uh adversarial examples
for the next couple minutes
do i know why the first example was
classified as a yield sign
um that's a good question i mean with
all these adversarial examples the
reason why they're being classified as
yield is pretty
confusing i think well
um for example like why is this turtle
being classified as a gun i'm really not
sure it doesn't look anything like a gun
and the textures don't look like a gun
the way these things are constructed
right is they're constructed by
optimization process you're basically
looking for
perturbations on say a normal turtle
texture that lead it to being a gun and
so there's no real interpretable reason
why say this looks like a yield sign or
this is being classified as a gun from
every angle
can i train these train on these
examples to correct classification
oh sorry i skipped a question how do we
define the non-robust feature versus
ah yes okay so this is an ad hoc
definition so the split just here is
just whether or not a feature can be
flipped by changing um the image
slightly in pixel space um and so that's
really the working definition here of
robust versus non-robust
and i think
if we were being more precise i think
this should really be split as saying
visually imperceptible is non-robust and
visually perceptible is possibly robust
and i think that's sort of a pretty
reasonable split anything that humans
really cannot visually tell
should not be being used as sort of
features as inputs to a
reliable prediction system
um can i train on these examples to
correct classification um i'm going to
try to interpret this question because
i'm not 100 sure i think what you're
describing is an idea called adversarial
training so the idea is to basically
instead of training on um
just the input image let's just go back
a little bit instead of trying on the
pandas right we try to train our system
to
basically classify this image the
adversarial image as being a pen right
and you might think okay this is good um
we can now make this a panda
but now we need to prevent um some other
sort of adversarially designed noise
from making sure that we look like a
panda right because there's probably
many many many different attacks that
will change this into a panda and so the
idea that you're describing here is
basically called adversarial training
and i think that's in
yes that's one of the earliest
defense approaches
and it's empirically reasonably
effective
um
but it's
you can still attack it by sort of more
sophisticated methods you can find
still visually imperceptible attacks
after adversarial training that breaks
the system so this is not really a
foolproof way
of um trying to make models more robust
it's better than nothing
um are you seeing yet unfound defenses
are needed for ml self-driving cars to
be secure from nefarious attacks i think
this is a great question
i think i was i'm being a little bit too
aggressive in terms of the things that
i'm saying right um
sort of it's an open question whether or
not these kinds of attacks
are really feasible in the real world or
whether or not they're things that we
should
worry about right like in the real world
i can easily cut out cut off a stop sign
you know using a saw and that's an
adversarial human attack but we're not
too worried about that attack and so
maybe we shouldn't be worried about
adversarial attacks on self-driving car
systems but i think
there are two things that this
highlights one thing is that we should
be a little bit careful when we deploy
these self-driving car systems right
like we should have fail safes that for
example don't rely just on vision
that seems pretty important we might
want to use like radar or lidar radar
doesn't work on soft people let's say
lidar um try to make sure we're not
going to run over people when we miss
detect the stop sign right like having
lots of orthogonal checks becomes
increasingly important once you realize
that there are ways to fool these vision
systems
um
and
i think people are working on sort of
provably robust machine learning systems
um maybe in settings like sort of
military applications those become truly
important um and so there is progress on
that but it's just that provably robust
systems achieve much worse average
accuracy than non-robust systems so
there's this big gap right now that we
don't really know how to close
um
okay in my opinion is research now
shifting towards reformulating models to
rely on robust features instead of
finding ad hoc defenses
um
that's a good question i think there is
still a big gap in terms of provably
robust defenses versus
um these what you might call ad hoc
defenses that work well for like say one
or two targeted attack types
um
but i think there's things like
randomized smoothing and procedures like
that now that sort of get the best of
both worlds in some sense they're
getting increasingly they're provably
correct in some framework and they're
getting increasingly better um and so i
think for high-stakes applications i
think we'll end up in a place where
we'll lose some average case accuracy
but not catastrophically so and we'll
still have sort of adversarially robust
models
that's sort of where i imagine the field
will go
um it does seem like ad-hoc defenses
keep getting broken so that's not really
a path towards like truly robust systems
even though they might make
for more useful systems overall if for
example adversarial training leads to
more interpretable latent features
um does producing adversarial attacks
require access to the model if so isn't
this just an issue of info security
equivalent of
uh
i can't pass that second sentence but
yes i agree
with this general sentiment as well
right so if you need access to the
internals of the model
then really at that point you know
you've rooted the system if you're
attacking say a medical imaging system
uh or you've like have access to
someone's car and if you're the mossad
you can probably like mess with their
brakes right um and so it's true that
those attack models are pretty obscure
and weird but there are for um what are
called white box attacks which only
require to evaluate the model
for one and for two um
a lot of systems are shared right so you
only need to learn to attack them
uh once and so if you're trying to
attack tesla's um auto driving system
you need to get a tesla you need to
figure out you know the adversarial
sticker that's going to make your system
go haywire and then you need to like
paste that everywhere right that doesn't
require a particularly sophisticated uh
threat model in order to execute
so i think there's models in which these
are sort of real and problematic even
though i think there's a lot of you know
questions and debate about whether or
not we should really care about this
like cost-benefit trade-offs of robust
versus non-robust systems and so on but
it's an important thing to keep in mind
right
okay
any other questions for the adversarial
examples part
okay
and so now i'm going to get to the last
part which given that this is a ai class
is maybe the most important of the
uh three failures of sort of machine
learning now in terms of robustness i
mean i think it's one of understanding
and
people sort of throw this word around a
lot that models don't really understand
and it's hard to pin down what
understanding is but it's very easy to
show when models don't understand and so
we can go through some examples here
we'll go through them again in more
detail
um but this is from an overview of what
people call shortcuts um in the citation
on the bottom
um and for example let's say we're
trying to caption the this image here
and so we need to you know describe in
text what's happening but really
sometimes these systems might just use
the background instead of actually
recognizing hills and skies and sheep
um
adversarial examples maybe you know
because we're recognizing textures and
not actually recognizing the shape of
things like teapots
and if we're doing medical image
diagnostics you know we might be looking
at markings on x-rays like what hospital
the x-ray came from instead of actually
performing prediction and so in all
these cases we're making use of these
pieces of information that shouldn't
really be central to the tasks like
they're not the core production tasks
that we care about and somehow the model
has picked them up and learned to do
really well um and i'm just gonna group
this broadly under this label of
shortcut learning
and the way to think about this is that
when we train models in machine learning
we're training them to do well well
directly on the training set and these
days we now expect them to do well on
the test set but really what we would
ideally like them to do as sort of
systems that reason and understand and
so on is that they perform well you know
on these like challenge sets like really
difficult examples that we've
constructed to break the model
um and so you can think about this as
you know there's a lot of possible rules
that work well in the training set and
there's fewer that work well on um test
sets and there's you know very very few
that work well on sort of these
challenge sets the intended true
reasoning that we would like our models
to extract
and so we can think about machine
learning today as you know we've gone
from this like
uh tan colored circle where we were
before to this you know blue colored
circle where we are now where we do all
the tests at but where we really want to
be is still further we want to make sure
we learn the right sort of mechanism
um and you may have heard this classic
ai story um of tank identification and i
think this is like a really old uh like
you know cold war kind of story where um
i'm gonna read this out loud you know
the army trained the program to
differentiate american tanks from
russian tanks it got 100 accuracy on a
test set but later people realized that
american tanks were photographed on a
sunny day and russian tanks were
photographed on a cloudy day and the
computer launched effect brightness
not actually detected tanks
and so you know this is exactly the kind
of problem that i'm talking about right
um where we have this extremely high
test accuracy and we are super happy but
then we realize we haven't learned
anything about the underlying task
um and this has been attributed to a lot
of different people it was i think
originally in written form on dreyfus's
textbook um but turns out it's an actual
real example this can't really be
attributed to any actual experiment run
by the army um the citation here is
warren he has a website where he has
gone through all the possible
attributions of this urban myth um
but really this urban myth has is so
popular i think at least in the ai
machine learning community because
there's a kernel of truth uh to this
um
sort of story and we're gonna go through
several examples of um
tasks today where there's these kinds of
failures
um so one of them that's kind of fun uh
is
this vision task apparently of where
people have tried to predict gender from
iris patterns
um and
there was apparently some belief that
this was a task that you can perform
because you can actually get reasonably
high test accuracy if you train cnns on
cropped images of viruses and you try to
predict gender
um but there's this paper
that identified that actually this is
not actually because of the iris it's
because um female eyes often have
mascara and that systematically shifts
the brightness of the images um and this
sort of
histogram tells sort of you know a
thousand words in one image and so on
the top one you see this distribution of
males and this x-axis here is the
average brightness of the image and so
the distributions look pretty similar
like males and females have a similar
brightness distribution
when females have no cosmetics on
but if you restrict yourself to females
with cosmetics you know this red
distribution shifts to the left
and the image becomes darker and so you
see that there's this you know very
strong confounding effect of the female
eyes having mascara therefore being
darker and therefore these systems
predicting quite well based on this
average uh darkness
even though really apparently wasn't
learning anything at all in terms of
this actual prediction task
another one from sort of the sort of
guern website and sort of the
investigation into this tank phenomenon
which is interesting is uh kaggle
fisheries competition where the task is
you're given images um of fishes being
caught on a fishing boat and the task is
to identify whether or not these uh
boats are catching fish illegally so
you're supposed to identify whether or
not these fish are part of a set of sort
of protected category of fish you're not
supposed to catch
i mean it turns out on the training set
you can do extremely well on this task
using a very simple heuristic
these images come from a relatively
small number of boats so you first
identify each boat and then you identify
for each boat whether or not they've
been catching illegal fish and this
approach does really well because it
turns out only a few fish or a few boats
um catch these illegal types of fish and
so by first identifying the boat and
then by identifying the fish you can get
extremely high accuracy even though you
have learned nothing about actually
performing this fish identification task
another one that seems maybe more high
stakes and problematic
is um in medical prediction there is a
lot of talk about you know tumor
identification or chest x-ray
sort of malignancy prediction
and in these cases right we it's pretty
important to ask whether or not we're
doing well because
these are high stakes situations then
you would like to make sure that you're
not being fooled by some sort of feature
that makes the cast easier than it
actually should be
and there's often claims now of these
systems performing
just as well as human doctors in terms
of their diagnostic accuracy and so on
and
one sort of really interesting um and
maybe a little problematic example is
when you have these sort of tumors um
sort of skin lesions that you're trying
to classify as whether or not they're
cancerous or not um doctors will often
put surgical markers to highlight
tumors that they think are more serious
than others just so that when someone
else is looking at them they can
immediately identify the more
problematic ones
and
the training set apparently for these
systems contain a lot of these markings
and so there was a examination into
these sort of tumor classification
systems where they artificially added uh
markings to these images as well as
cropped out markings from already marked
images and they show that they can
basically flip the classification output
of these systems
and so in some ways the high accuracy of
these kinds of classification systems
are not because they're identifying
humors it's because they're piggybacking
on humans who have already in many cases
classified the tumors as being malignant
or not
um an early um problem that someone
identified in one of the earlier works
and oh sorry identification
of this esteva in 2011 is when people
are trying to identify whether or not
tumors are malignant when in serious
cases people would include rulers to
show how big the tumor is and so the
existence of a ruler would serve as a
sort of spurious correlation or a
confounder
in terms of
uh whether or not a tumor was malignant
and finally
one that i think people are now aware
about but initially i think people are
um
sort of not as aware of is that hospital
id often serves as a really reliable
indicator of both sort of base risk
level as well as the type of procedures
being performed at a hospital
and this you can think of as like the
analogous to the boat example in the
fishing problem where if you identify
hospitals that say have a lot of
smokers you're going to much more likely
find
cancer in lung chest x-rays from those
types of hospitals and so it's really
important to try to remove the effect of
sort of identifying the hospital and
then identifying the base risk
um
a really interesting one i wasn't aware
of in image classification until
yesterday or so is um pascal voc
is a pretty common uh object innovation
data set and uh
a bias that's been identified is that
the horse class for this
i guess was taken by a single horse
photographer who put in watermarks at
the bottom left of the image so around
20 of the horse images have a watermark
and reliable classification systems just
learn to pick up on the watermark so you
can make cars um classified as horses as
long as you add the watermark on the
bottom right
and so this is something where unless
you really carefully looked at the data
set you probably won't even realize that
this kind of bias exists until you've
actually um
sort of carefully examined an
adversarially examine the data sets that
you have
sort of finally
there is
i've mostly talked about vision
examples thus far but this is a
this sort of shortcuts and lack of
understanding
is a problem that's common to
every area and i'm going to give
probably a very well-known example in
natural language processing
the task here is entailment prediction
so you're given a pair of sentences one
is called the premise and another one is
called the hypothesis so the first one
is a sentence like the economy could be
better
and the second one is a sentence like
the economy has never been better
and the goal here is to say does the
hypothesis logically follow from the
statement made in the premise and so if
they follow you say it's entailed if
it's contradicted you say it's a
contradiction and if it's neither you
say it's neither and so it's a
three-class classification problem and
the way these tasks are sorry the way
these examples are constructed is
through crowdsourcing where you extract
the premise sentence from some sort of
large internet text
or newswire text i guess um and you have
a label that you randomly pick so you
say i have a premise and it's going to
be a contradiction and then you ask
crowd workers to write down a
contradiction so they write something
like the economy has never been better
right
and so
uh what happens here is that crowd
workers because they're writing the
hypothesis text
after you're seeing the label have
systematic biases and the bias that's
really strong is this negation
where they learn that negation is often
or sorry where the bias is that when
something's not entailed they use
negation and so a model will often learn
to associate the negation or lack
thereof with the outcome label and so
instead of actually doing these sort of
entailment tasks they often pick up
these negation biases and even more
problematically
systems have what's called or sorry
what's called a hypothesis-only baseline
where you don't even look at the premise
can do extremely well right and there's
no way to do well on this task while
looking just at the hypothesis right
because how can you know
that the hypothesis is entailed from the
premise while only just looking at one
and so this shows like this really
strong bias that these crowd workers put
into this data set
and so this has kind of serious
implications for the project of
pushing
machine learning and getting towards
understanding and general ai right
because
thus far all of machine learning has
been predicated on benchmark progress
and that's the way in which the field
has really grown and done well you know
imagenet and mnli and these sort of
well-known tasks you get everyone
together and we push on these numbers
and we hope that improvements in these
benchmark performances lead to
understanding but it's clear that
because of these biases that may not
necessarily be the case right and so
like we need a different sort of
paradigm to link machine learning
performance to understanding
and the other problem that i hope by
sort of going over so many examples i
was able to impress upon you
is that you know there are so many
shortcuts right and like you know in
this uh negation bias from crowd workers
like you wouldn't know about this unless
you sort of looked at the data set
carefully after being told that there
was a bias right where the water marks
were horses like i don't even know how
they found that given that how sort of
minor that is
so it becomes really hard to say like
we're just going to construct a data set
free of shortcuts like when you're told
about these shortcuts afterwards it
seems really obvious but like how can
you construct a shortcut free data set
um
and so that's sort of the real challenge
now if we think that we can't get data
sets free of these shortcuts and these
biases and these minority groups you
know we need a new way of sort of trying
to make sure that our models really
learn the right thing
um and i'm going to stop here for a
moment to sort of talk about shortcuts
and understanding and hopefully people
have lots of questions because i think
this one is a fun one uh in terms of
thinking about how machine learning
really stay ai and so on
sure um
just thinking about like some committee
modeling and and um you know i'm coming
back to that stop sign with the patches
that seem as a yield sign
if you had um
you know does it make more sense to use
one big model trained on every piece of
data you can find
or does it make sense to you know
train a bunch of models on some
partitions of the data
that might overlap in some way and then
combine those votes in order to make it
less
um
uh i'm sort of um
different sort of robotically um
easily fooled in a robotic way um
yeah i think that's um a generally good
thing to do like so
i guess there's two answers and like the
more general one
is to think about the trade-off between
uh model capacity
and your ability to fit these like sort
of minority groups or these like
shortcuts right so
the idea you're describing let's say we
have you know 10 or like 100 different
models right and we fit them to
different parts of the data then we
might have a model that's dedicated to
shortcuts but we might also have a model
that like really learns the right thing
right
um and so you know the more flexible our
model the bigger our sort of model class
the more we can say like part of the
model might dedicate the shortcuts but
that's okay because the rest of our
model will still learn the right thing
right but that's sort of still a hope
there's no real guarantee that this will
happen and if the shortcuts are strong
enough that's what the model will learn
so i think
it seems really important um to have
bigger capacity models like that's sort
of given but you know how can we learn
um big models well like without
overfitting how can we make sure that
they still learn sort of the right thing
like if one part of the model fits the
shortcuts how can we make sure the rest
of it learns to do the right sort of
prediction without shortcuts that's sort
of the open question i think in this
area yeah
um
[Music]
there was a question for image
segmentation do we have a way to know
which part of the image contribute to
the prediction we could call it
prediction traceability yes
um so
i of course glossed over quite a bit but
the this paper la pushkin 2019 um here
is exactly about that is about trying to
identify or to attribute um
predictions to parts of the image using
interpretability methods and that's how
they found i think this horse
problem where they attributed
predictions to locations and they found
that for horses they were always
localized to the bottom right and it was
because of this watermark and so i think
a big
important use case of interpretability
methods is exactly this
it's to identify these kinds of
shortcuts by attributing predictions to
locations in the image or to subgroups
in the data set
um
going along the above comment are there
methods of finding what parts of the
image or data example has high weights
associated with it yes
um so
the general approach i think that people
have i think there's of course many
different methods but
shapley values are a pretty general
framework you can sort of think about
um
the analogy is kind of like this think
about each pixel or each region or
subpart of the image as participating in
the prediction and you can ask when i
remove that part of the image
how much does the prediction accuracy go
down right
and so you can do that after sort of
randomly removing other parts of the
image so you randomly remove the other
parts of the image like drop random
pixels and then you drop the part you're
interested in you ask on average how
much more accuracy does this uh part
that i'm interested in give me right and
that's sort of this estimate called the
shampoo value
and a punggway i think who is here has a
paper on you know approximations to that
based on the influence function so
there's all sorts of ways um in the
interpretability community about doing
what's called feature attribution
um another question for a problem with
discrimination would a
reasonable approach be to adopt active
learning by default where the model can
train with more emphasis on wrongly
categorized examples then the hope is
that the model could steer itself away
from the initial biases over time or is
it not as simple yeah so that's um
obviously sort of uh
actually one way around it right like
when you can collect your own data and
you have the ability to know what you're
getting wrong
then you know collecting data in the
places where you're wrong serves as a
negative feedback loop right you get
more data where you're wrong your model
gets the training signal it needs to
correct
um and so eventually you'll learn the
right thing it's just that active
learning on the scale that you need is
very very challenging right like can you
actively collect image net size style
data very challenging also very
challenging to know what parts of the
data you're doing badly on right um you
need to know well enough to say oh the
part of the data i'm doing badly on is
horses without the watermark right
that's sort of a hard thing to be able
to say so you need to know what you
don't know which is almost equally as
challenging as robustness
um oh wow there's a lot of questions now
um
physicians are experimenting in
end-of-life care based on ai to nudge
conversations do you have any
suggestions for patients
and doctors
um
that is yeah that's very challenging i
do think one important thing
about sort of these high stakes settings
is to think about sort of the
alternative and the whole
decision systems that they're part of
right um
so say medical diagnosis or i'll give
another example i'm more familiar with
which is um predicting whether or not
someone will commit crime again and so
should be released for parole right
these are both really high stakes
prediction tasks and the way they're
performed is there's you know a machine
learning system and the human and they
sort of jointly make a decision and so
you need to think about not only the
machine learning system which is sort of
what i've talked about here but also the
human part right and how they integrate
and how their decisions get combined
together um i think that's actually the
important part like how do humans
override the machines how do they
incorporate the suggestions of the
machines even more so than the
predictions which i think
need to always be taken uh carefully um
next one how can we combine models
objectives to gain greater understanding
of the world and to combine it to create
intelligent behavior um
yeah i think this is uh this is
basically the
the open question right the unfortunate
thing that we don't know how to do um
and i think that's sort of the thing
that we are struggling with in sort of
the robustness uh generalization
literature like what is the right
approach and i think there's not really
even a consensus is it like more data
collection is it smarter ways of
training the model or is it better
models um it's
not clear yet what the right way is yet
unfortunately you don't have a great
answer beyond that
um
for shortcuts i think even people use
shortcuts to identify something um do we
have some way to understand shortcuts
based on training data
yeah this is a good point um so humans
will also use shortcuts but i think
the important thing here is that these
shortcuts are a lot more crude than the
humans ones that we use
and at some level they don't even pass
basic sanity checks right like for
entailment we know that the output
should depend on both the both the
inputs but in reality it's only
depending on the hypothesis which is
very problematic
and what people do today is they
have these sort of challenge sets like
examine the performance of a model just
based on the hypothesis and these kinds
of sort of what are close to those are
unit tests
help catch these kinds of shortcuts in
many cases so i think
um one way to detect them is things like
that like our model shouldn't be
sensitive to certain perturbations or it
should be sensitive certain
perturbations when you go off of those
kinds of assertions
is there currently a correlation between
model capacity and number of shortcuts
employed are larger models more likely
to happen on the correct correlations or
are smaller models more likely to use
shortcuts
that's a good question i think
the general sense that i get from
reading the literature is that smaller
models are more likely to use shortcuts
in many ways um for example in this
paper about sort of watermark
based shortcuts
linear models did a lot worse like they
would really pick up heavily on these
watermarks whereas cnns did so um with
less weights and less frequency
um and i think generally that's true
that like large capacity models trained
with a lot of data can use some of its
capacity just to model the shortcuts and
it'll still do well on the data without
shortcuts as long as they exist but
really the key thing here is like you
need to at least see some data without
the shortcut pattern
um
how much are you oh i already answered
okay great
yeah so i wanna get into the breakout
now actually especially because someone
asked the question you know uh what sort
of the solution and you know are humans
robust so um if woody you could uh drop
us into a breakout session for say uh
five or six minutes
um it would be great to talk about these
two questions so um the first one is are
the brittleness issues inevitable you
know what do you think are the solutions
like what are the right approaches that
you think of i mean the second question
is are humans robust um and you know if
you think so then what's the key
ingredient that makes humans robust or
more robust than machines
awesome yes i'll create the breakout
rooms if everyone wants to take a quick
screenshot or try to remember these i'll
post the questions in the chat as well
but they won't be in the breakout
session
oh
okay
great um i think i'm unmuted right let's
see
yes okay great all right excellent
all right so i'll go through the second
part a little bit quicker um i'm glad
that we got so many good questions on
the first part which is the more
important of the two parts of this talk
and the second part is thinking a little
bit about how can we do learning how can
we fix these problems and the kinds of
research that
percy and i and others in stanford have
been doing and so the key problem right
that i think you should keep in mind
with all this is that the training
distribution is very different from the
test distribution this is the root of
all evil for these robustness problems
um and so
we need to think about you know is the
limitation that we can't generalize from
train to test inevitable or can we come
up with some clever data collection
schemes or model training mechanisms
that allow us to generalize um and so to
do this we need to think a little bit
about you know
how distributions can shift
and so i'll give you a little bit of
definitions the first one is like
covariate shift and this is what you
usually think of when people say the
distributions are different so you might
get you know these let's say you're
making a face recognizer you have these
really nice welded portraits in the
training data and at test time you're
using it with cctvs so all sorts of
different environments but the
underlying task is the same and there
should be a single predictor that does
well both on portraits and images
cropped from cctvs
another example is label shift where you
know the input features look similar but
now the output labels distribution has
shifted so for example if you're making
a face recognizer and at training time
you know you need really precise
matching so you're only going to be
calling detections when the images look
exactly the same but at test time you
know you're making a product for your
camera and so it can be a little bit
looser and so you might deal with blurry
images and so on and so the limits test
for this is you know you have the same
predictor but you're changing your
threshold you're just saying it's okay
if you know i'm a little bit less
confident i'm still gonna make the call
and this is you know an instance of
label shift
and the final one that is basically
intractable in all cases is concept
drift um and so here you know you might
have a prediction task where you're
trying to initially recognize um faces
of you know the same people but then at
test time you want to match people
across time like young pictures and old
pictures the task is fundamentally
different right like whether or not
you're matching the same person or
person shifted in time and so no one
predictor is going to do really well on
both of these tasks and so there's sort
of a fundamental change on in the task
definition
i mean i'm going to go over to sort of
ways to deal with all these problems the
first one is we're just going to collect
more data like someone sort of talked
about this as a question earlier and
this is sort of the key thing right like
if we get more data we can do a lot more
things and the second part is a little
bit more ambitious and it's going to say
you know let's try to only do with what
data we have so the first idea is let's
just say you know
we're going to try to generalize to a
test set and we're just going to collect
more data so a classic example of this
kind of task is um you're recognizing
digits so you have images of digits the
left one is mnist which is really old
usps even older actually an svhn which
is a more modern recognized digits from
um i think uh male
numbers that are taken from the wild so
in all of these cases you need to output
the number right like this one's a 2
this one's a 7 and so on
we're collecting new data let's say we
trained a model on mnist and we want to
do well on svhn at test time and so this
is a distribution shift
um but we might be able to collect more
data right it's unrealistic to maybe say
we only have this and we have to predict
this
and so
what we might have is we might be able
to collect some unlabeled data from svhn
right like we can't afford someone
labeling them by hand but we might just
be able to get the images and this is
called unsupervised domain adaptation
um and if we can collect labels that's
all called um supervised domain
adaptation and that's even better
and so we can ask like when can we do
learning right like if we're in
covariate shift and we have this like
source data we might be able to do
learning because we have a better model
that can adapt to these different kinds
of distribution shifts that occur
so the general thing that you should
sort of think about is you know if we're
in covariate shift settings and
we have source domain data so unlabeled
data from our target distribution
then we can actually sometimes
generalize to our target task even
though we don't have labels
um
and so this is sort of the setting that
we're going to be talking about for the
rest of the talk the rest of the couple
minutes of this talk where we're going
to say you know we have this covariate
shift problem where the prediction task
is fundamentally the same
and how can we generalize
so
the easiest thing to do and the most
classic thing to do is re-weighting so
let's say we have training data that's
90 frontal images but 10
images taken from the side and we want
to generalize the test data that's 50 50
front and side right so how can we do
this well let's just re-weight the data
set so each frontal facing image counts
for less and each side facing image
counts for more right so we've
artificially rebalanced the data and
this gives us this like assumption-free
way of getting estimates of how well our
model will perform on this sort of 50 50
test set and you know this applies to
all of what i've talked about before
like if your data is imbalanced it has a
minority group or maybe has shortcuts
maybe we can rebalance it to get rid of
all these problems right
so are we done
no uh because you know even though i
talked about it that way if we re
shuffle or like restructure the data set
you know the training data 100 percent
men and the test date is 100 women so
there's no overlap and if we try to
reweight this data we're going to get
infinite error right because we need to
infinitely update the women that we
don't have in our training data so this
is the fundamental problem with all
these approaches like when you don't
have any overlap your estimates all blow
up and go to infinity
and so in the real world
everything is non-overlapping and so
usually these kinds of estimates don't
work
but intuitively we might think you know
these kinds of tasks are possible and
the reason why you know um you and i and
many others think this is possible is
this intuition right like let's say we
have training data that's blue images
and test data that's orange images like
clearly there is no overlap between any
of these images right they're on
different color channels
um but if we desaturate the images we
can perform prediction on the
desaturated image and we'll get really
good performance right
and so the intuition that if we can't
distinguish the two domains because
we've desaturated the images we might do
really well and this is the idea behind
you know most of modern domain
adaptation where you learn to represent
your data in a space that doesn't change
when you go from training to test
distribution and so you measure how much
your
data changes in this sort of a higher
level representation and if your data is
close then you're going to do really
well and the sort of thing to keep in
mind is you know your test performance
is going to be your training data's
performance plus some sort of distance
that measures how different the training
and test distributions are
and if you keep this small you're going
to do really well
and so you can think about this sort of
very simply as saying you know this gap
you know the test error of a model is
the source performance how well we do on
the training data and the gap between
trainer and tester
and
this idea is that you know we're going
to look at a domain distance where no
matter what model we pick we're going to
do well because the distributions look
so similar right like if images are
desaturated and they look identical it
doesn't matter what the model is they do
identically
and so if we do well on the source
domain and the domain distance is low we
might be able to generalize
and this is really interesting and
optimistic right like these all seem
like things that we can measure and
think about and they give us conditions
under which we might be able to do well
on a test distribution and there's been
a lot of work over the last almost two
decades now um on these kinds of domain
distances and bounds and how you can
learn from unlabeled data
um and they give great intuition they
let you think carefully about these
kinds of problems but unfortunately if
you try to actually compute these bounds
you know what's my guarantee of test
error they're usually vacuous so you'll
say
things like the accuracy will be greater
than zero and the error will be uh less
than one which is not super helpful
and um just to go over how these kinds
of things often work in practice
domain distance is the thing i just
described is the basis for a lot of
these modern domain adaptation methods
and the key idea is that neural nets are
everywhere because neural nets work
and you use them as a way to measure the
domain distance
and the idea here is that you have one
part of your model maximizing
performance on the training data and you
have another part of the model making
sure that you can't distinguish between
the training and the data distribution
on this sort of what's called like a
bottleneck feature space where
at this level your training and test
data should be indistinguishable and yet
useful for actually doing the task
and so you know we have this hope that
you know we have this re-weighting thing
which has no model dependence um and
this model-based domain
distances that you know requires us to
carefully construct a neural network but
on the other hand that's the only way we
can get these things to work in the real
world right like with re-weighting often
these weights are infinity and so
there's no free lunch we either need
model assumptions or assumptions about
overlap on the domain
um but if we have one of those and
unlabeled data on the test domain we can
actually sometimes do well
the other approach that i'm go over a
little quickly because i'm running low
on time
i can describe very uh at a very high
level as this idea right
as i said before the main issue is that
our training distribution and the test
distribution are different right and if
they were the same we'd be done but
they're not
but what if i told you i give you a list
of 100 possible test distributions and i
say your true test distribution is going
to be one amongst these hundred right
then we can train a model to do well on
all of these right we just go through
each one of these test sets and we say
our model has to do well on the worst
one and if we can get a model that works
on all of them we know that our model is
going to do well in the true test set so
this is thinking about you know a
potential set of test distributions and
considering the worst case and this is
what's called a min and max optimization
problem
so we're going to find the best model
that's the min part that works well over
the worst possible potential test set
and that's the max part and this idea is
going to work whenever the true test set
um is contained in this uncertainty
queue right we're saying worst case over
this big q which is the set of potential
test distributions and this fails
whenever q is too small or two bit if q
doesn't contain the real test
distribution you've got no guarantees if
q is so big that it contains everything
then your model is going to be
so pessimistic right because it has to
be prepared for any possible
distribution that's just going to
predict um 50 50 or you know something
vacuous for all of your inputs
i'm going to skip over a bit of examples
and i'm going to go to this slide
and say
these kinds of ideas can be applied in
each one of the settings that i
described before
talking about minority groups in
fairness or adversarial examples or
understanding by carefully choosing the
kinds of worst-case groups
in the case of minority groups we
basically explicitly list out all the
possible minorities that we care about
and we consider the worst case
performance over all of those
in adversarial examples we know that
these images before and after
perturbation are close so we consider
all distributions that are nearby each
other in pixel space and then we
maximize over the worst case over those
and then for shortcuts what we can do is
we can explicitly construct groups that
don't contain some of these shortcuts
and we enumerate all such groups and
then make sure that these worst case
groups work well so for example
if we have a model that relies too much
on backgrounds we construct
subgroups of the data that have sort of
mismatching backgrounds and objects
so the
to basically wrap up here right the
limits of this kind of approach is that
if we pick too small of a worst case
group we got no robustness and if we
pick too broad of a worst case group we
get vacuous models and there's no simple
or general principle for designing these
losses even though this approach gives
us really nice ways of thinking about
and optimizing models for the worst case
and getting guarantees
okay i'm going to wrap up there if
anyone has questions
i would be happy to
answer them i can stay for a little bit
longer
and chat if people have questions
all right maybe we should just uh thank
tatsu for his really insightful and
interesting talk
and then maybe
run off if they have to go
so thanks tata
thank you
really a lot of interesting things food
for thought so i hope that everyone is
kind of have their eyes opened with
respect to all the different problems
that we're we're seeing and hopefully
motivated to help
solve some of these because i think
there's a lot of interesting open
research questions here